let's go next to uh let's go to schizo
from north carolina schizo you're on the
air
hey can you hear me yes i can
awesome
uh i had a question so
in one of your episodes
um on may 3rd you were talking about
esper withholding information
to make money on a book
and you mentioned something you had
talked about
you not agreeing with
uh conservatism
could you explain exactly what that what
that what you mean by that and
i'm not a conservative i'm just
kind of wondering what your opinion is
on it it you're saying what like why am
i not a conservative you're saying
that's the question no no you so you
said you had you disagree with
conservatism
i'm not a conservative yeah i i don't
agree with conservative ideas i'm a
progressive but
are you saying like
i'm not trying to particularly
because um what you were talking about
you said something that
the whole aspect so the point you made
was that esper was basically like you
could say that what he did with holding
that information being treasonous
and i agree with that that's an
interesting point
and then you had said that this isn't
conservatism you disagree with
conservatism and my question is like
what is
what is it about conservatism that you
disagree with apart from you know being
a progressive
oh i guess you're asking me my political
philosophy i mean i disagree with the
economic ideas of the of conservatism
and i disagree with the social ideas of
conservatism i think the economic ideas
have been debunked empirically and i
think the social ideas are retrograde
antiquated and um completely the
opposite of of modernity i mean i don't
know i don't know if i can lay out on
every issue my political philosophy but
like my entire show is based on the idea
that i'm a progressive and i think that
those conservative ideas are bad and are
bad for the country and bad for the
people
okay i understood yeah because i i'm
finding myself to be more progressive
i've never felt or
been aligned with conservatism i was
just curious because
my awakening
um from like political awakening was
2020 and i voted for biden because at
the time i didn't really understand
politic politics and stuff like that but
i
voted for biden because trump just
seemed like
not the best choice
and i'm finding myself that that was the
best choice
um for 2020 but i'm fine which was which
was the best choice for 2020. biting
okay okay and how old were you in 2020
i was
28.
wow so you didn't you could have voted
in 2016 and you could have voted in 2012
but you didn't
right and there's a bit of a backstory
that obviously i'm not going to go into
for
the time
um but yeah at the time i uh
so yeah i voted for biden and one of the
other things i wanted to ask or or i
guess kind of like tell you was
the interviews that you've been having
with republican candidates i've been
enjoying a lot and not from like a
laughing at them
for still not accepting like that gut
check question where who is currently
the president of the us and they will
just dance around and i love it because
it makes me it's kind of like
you you're not trying to
uh directly
attack that person but the people who
are watching can kind of see hey this is
the idea that these people are having
and it sort of gets the people to kind
of like think about
why do they think that way and the
reason why i've been enjoying that is
because i am currently surrounded by a
lot of
conservative republican people
who
i don't think understand conservatism
and what they're doing is they're just
kind of repeating the talking points and
believing the conspiracies and they
don't really have a good basis for
their their their political views well
that's very common
right and
i guess that's sort of my point is
why you disagree with it because i kind
of wanted your take on it because i i'm
still like in that journey where i'm
trying to understand
you know politics in that way
well listen i lay out all my political
views on my show any clip you find
that's me laying out my political views
so schizo from north carolina i very
much appreciate the call
i am going to move on because i've got a
bunch of other people here waiting let's
go next to daniel from texas daniel
welcome what's on your mind today
hey david cameron just barely daniel
what's going on
sorry i'll try to get closer to mike now
um
i was just uh uh
sorry my uh
trying to jumble this morning
no
um
i'm from texas it actually says but um
i've been looking at a lot of the races
um throughout the country and one of the
ones that i'm honestly most interested
in seeing the outcome of is louisiana's
senate race with gary chambers
i was wondering what your thoughts might
be about uh him whether you think he has
the uh um
had a chance to win and
uh his platform and all that you know i
don't really know that much about that
race that's not one of the ones i've
been following uh super closely
but it seemed this to be to be accurate
this is the race in which the incumbent
is the republican senator john kennedy
who's cuckoo for cocoa puffs and then
you've got gary chambers and then
there's a couple of other candidates as
well right it's so it's like a
nonpartisan
um election that's done there it's is
it's a bit of a different system
yeah kind of from what i've been able to
figure out it's like basically i guess
both are gonna be running at the same
time yeah
with chambers being like just under
uh the incumbent the other two kind of
like
yeah it looks like they have their
primary on november 8th and then it it
looks like the top two will go to sort
of like the final election on december
10th yeah listen i don't know much about
gary chambers i know that john kennedy
is a disaster so
i i mean i it would be improper for me
to say i support chambers only because
he's not kennedy because i don't really
know anything about him but kennedy is
not a good guy and i support removing
him but i'd have to look more into the
race to be able to say any more about it
okay
oh boy all right now we're losing you
daniel the connection's going haywire so
i'm going to let you go